we're gonna open the boxes he's got 51
this is the moment of truth this is the
moment of truth I I'm gonna leave our
pip up for his reaction and or mine it
doesn't want hurt me as much because
it's not my actual crates but here we go
good luck to you sir always a legendary
already gold oh that's a new spray oh
yeah they do a new spray the big-time
fails nice bureau emote laughing one
next openly Fox nothing up there's new
icons as well of course like I said
they're gonna orangey you out
and sadness
yeah it hurts more because we did get a
legendary and I feel like it's like one
in like ten people they they start you
off with one then they're like yeah cool
who's that for I was just anyone okay we
got a chance background to it to that
before all right so we got a sold your
skin it's alright
not necessarily one that that Joey
wanted but maybe by the time we're done
opening boxes you'll have three thousand
you can just buy the junker stolen
hopefully spill out another one back to
back back to back and you play on
alright keep it going good
we're on a mini roll here oh wow three
in a row it's it's so far I've been
better than I like that young is that
Hans over again that's Hans oh that's
pretty cool so three in a row pretty
good doing alright we're doing okay
right now three epochs in a row going
old it's pretty cool though it's just
really hard to get play the game all
these high light inches are really sick
though yeah agreed
it's a dud Oh another like Young's Aria
you'll have like the QT version of them
with the candy I guess I imagine this
has to be fun for like the art team
stuff till they're bigger than when I
forget to make a new skin yeah design
boring it would be if they just need to
support like the regular man like no no
cool events like there's nothing I'm Pat
man says all I want to junk rat we agree
oh we got the diva rip rip she goes out
the way she lived with the peace side
there's Doritos in the back to be
where's that mountain dude though I took
it down there with her mm-hmm I like how
the music is different depending on the
rarity that you get okay with a bucket
head [ __ ] head sitting on it we keep
getting this again this is buried in the
sand something we got like 30 something
more to go oh you got a intro thing so
there are eight rows oh okay we did not
go through the intros
that's pretty cool I need that I got I
play a lot of Reaper oh man I really
don't want to have to buy crates later
okay we got a visual
no I think I think all the Halloween
stuff has the like the moon or whatever
behind it right right and the bat or
whatever
this is this I don't know it's all
heroes it says right I can't equipment
sometimes it has that weird bug thing or
if you go back out and back in
I work oh this thing of course of course
that reprint row though I agree guys
hope you got voice line yeah sure
trick-or-treat oh god legendary wrecked
and we got a freaking dupe of the stupid
bastion up really somebody said there's
a Genji skin there wasn't right I don't
we'll check after yeah if there's a
Genji skin that's got to be pretty cool
so far we've gotten to like legendaries
one was gold and one was like an old
skin which is really painful because you
usually only get about another one there
it is that's that's probably the one I
want the most Roadhog the junk Ensign
monsters that way I don't play road hog
enough but come on how can you know with
this he's the man because I can't play
true tank so like I play road hog
because he's like in the in-between yeah
he's like I beat people all his stomach
and this I love this pipe going into it
oh there's Genji highlight intro oh that
is cool plate one more time that's
pretty cool nice alright maybe that's
what you guys are talking about that was
pretty sweet
okay I'm a 31 so died about five more
maybe yeah got a good about okay Genji
Genji with a nice victory pose alright
heroes never die they just come back a
zombies chillin okay Oh young Winston
though fine it's cool I like it
you play Winston along the tracer
getting new skin though but we got that
Farah do we get this again okay no no no
something else
I mean All Things Considered it's been
pretty good though I want to say the
event is out guys so yeah you've opened
half your boxes we've already gotten
like three epochs one legendary yeah so
that's pretty good you've netted like
1300 gold so I'm halfway to General
Grant
yeah Jenkins Stein it's gonna be fine
watch you got 26 boxes I bet you you're
gonna get it or get enough gold
I'm confident should we open the oh yeah
do it going just keep going let's let it
all ride right here got it right here
right I know you know okay this is the
worst feeling is getting a legendary
dupe skin you know why it's less than an
epic skin cost it's 200 coins why is it
not 500 a box of gold is 500 you should
at least get 500 that is got to tracer
voice lines as well that is still one of
my biggest pet peeves about like opening
boxes that is like the one thing that is
accessible they give you a for a tube
for a dupe legendary it's like kind of
ridiculous because it makes you feel
like oh my golly generic oh I got 200
gold
that the moment of anticipation when you
see it flying up in the air and then
when that just lands and you're like the
fog on that I guess it I kind of do
actually oh you know what the reaper
wanna be pretty cool to get to not
peanut butter yeah I think people are
having Q problems but just thank you
it's pretty fast usually poke tracers
fine
yeah pretty typical see you're only a
thousand gold away from buying the junk
that because of all the duplicates I'm
getting well there's like a Reaper like
candy the candy yeah and do City doop
city if you look at all the candy here
it's all based off the characters icons
and stuff up lucio line yeah killed it
can you buy skins with coins yes it's
just three times the cost
so legendaries are three thousand epics
or 750 it's kind of ridiculous but it is
what it is Oh Symmetra that's alright
it's okay we are running low took up
windings
okay gold is good okay this is new oh
yeah nice nice nice alright show really
professional equipped yeah you guys
start a game like it's a bat right
supposed to be I think so yeah it's kind
of funny that it doesn't show but that's
cool I like it we're inching our way to
that junk oh not a duplicate at least
it's not a do oh there's a mate there's
a may intro to college Oh
that's pretty good
I need that cold ice cream I need that
that's pretty good you know what else I
wish you could do I wish you get like
sell skins like I'm like a marketplace
like no maybe that's too much or traits
getting to your friends no I wouldn't
advocate selling them it's just gonna
turn to the right kind of thing but I
would like to trade I'm like if somebody
plays like one character a lot and
you're like okay I'll trade you that
skin for one of your other ones always
keep you can choose to keep the
duplicates if you want to to try them
yeah 20 to 200 coins won't be enough
unless you do the epic well played the
new brawl mode again in a second and
then maybe like one match with some like
new skins or something like competitive
match and then we'll see where we're at
okay there we go
all right so we've got two legendary
skins um new ones and then we got one
dupe which was very unfortunate but hey
that's pretty cool that's a good one you
got what 14 boxes I feel like you got a
good you got a good chance
emo Zarya strikes again she always says
no
yeah which is brutal
you need 800 gold to get your and the
dupes are real someone making a comment
that aren't enough to trade yeah but I
think to Joey's point if you have dupes
if you traded your dupes away I think
that's not bad but yeah but they
wouldn't never do that because then
you'll never buy boxes yeah so Oh money
yeah it's a money thing let's be real
here I mean they tried the whole sell
stuff with like Diablo and that kind of
fell on its face so mercy skiing yep oh
we are winning we are winning we are
winning today that's three new legendary
skins he got the one he wanted
everything from here on out is just a
bonus is just a bonus hope for the
Reaper one right here oh my god this guy
greedy greedy man oh so greedy is there
again g-scan there is pretty cool
yeah that's cool I like it though six
I'd be surprised if you got another
legendary I mean I wouldn't be shocked
but I'm pretty sure you're not gonna get
another one seven seven boxes I'm trying
to use reverse psychology it's not
working oh you got a the widow at least
we're getting most of the posed I don't
know I feel like I don't know if it's
just your luck oh oh
that's your third one but my luck like I
said the first time when I did the
Summer Games ones was really awful like
really compared to my second set so I
guess it's just orangey is RNG victory
poses probably and you've gotten a bunch
of the new highlight intros - so more
gold how much you're close you're close
to being like goodbye just like Reaper
or like Reinhard or whatever are you
guys playing overwatch lotto heck yeah
we are we should go play the lotto I
mean considering how many of the skins
you got that's the old one I've got two
chances nope you got any Winston angry
Winston it's good it's a carry last box
Mona truth Reaper or no Reaper he's so
sick if you got it no didn't think so
Oh double honest stuff yeah yeah I'm
scared
pretty fruit Oh 250 you're like what 400
so that was pretty good 2,300 gold was
it for legendary games or three four if
you count the dupe that dude junk well
you got two on top of that too though
right like you got the Gothic Zarya you
got the young gun G got the soldier well
that wasn't a legendary though right
yeah yeah so he got like I think six
legendary is total one dupe and then two
old ones and then three new ones yes
there is no Kenji yeah Halloween costume
but he had the intro which you have now
which is the pumpkin carving yeah
boom okay so look
you